la baie du robert sera la deuxième halte
des agents des affaires maritimes qui
sillonne depuis 4 heures du matin les
zones identifiées ou se reproduisent des
oursins blanc 200 bateaux de pêche
professionnelle ont été autorisés à
extraire les chats dont de leur père aux
abords de l'île et madame une première
rencontre avec un patron de pêche donne
des retours encourageants sur la qualité
des produits pêchés
c'est pas mal mais l'année dernière
mieux ici cette zone là tu viens d
emblée les braconniers sont la hantise
des professionnels un danger pour
assurer la conservation de la ressource
et la régénération
les stocks du hx1 blanc une
réglementation existe pour préserver
l'espèce le nombre de plongeurs par
exemple est limité à trois par
embarcation vos déposé un dossier auprès
du comité des pêches
il nous revient ensuite après qu'il fait
marrer professionnelle en marquer donc
enrôler et puis il faut avoir un certain
nombre de conditions un point d'ensemble
de conditions en particulier
évidemment de visite médicale à jour
pour que les gars puissent avoir une
aptitude de plongée voilà et puis
surtout on regarde si la personne a un
droit de pêche c'est à dire s'il a
déclaré dans le passé des belles choses
ensemble
cette activité n'est pas autorisée dans
les cantonnements pollué par la
chlordécone la pêche aux oursins est à
la fois une tradition et surtout le
moyen pour les professionnels d'arrondir
leurs fins de mois
financièrement ça peut rapporter jusqu'à
2000 euros par jour pour tout le monde
ok les casseurs et puis à les plongeurs
ceux qui travaillent quand même le plus
à parts égales ont fait pas d'eux y'a
pas plus pour le capitaine c'est à parts
égales on travaille tous pareils la baie
du trésor est l'une des zones les plus
dangereuses à cause des courants
pourtant nombre de candidats la récolte
n'ont pas hésité à venir profiter du
filon durant dix jours le caviar
descente y sera extrait dans les eaux
martiniquaise
d'ailleurs il y en a qui salivent déjà à
l'idée de manger une bonne tête de
chadron